ok ya regresamos y vamos a continuar en
donde nos quedamos sabemos entonces que
la velocidad es la aceleración por el
tiempo aquí lo escribimos de una manera
un poco más formal donde la velocidad
final es igual a la velocidad inicial
más la aceleración por el tiempo
y de hecho debemos estar conscientes que
esta velocidad en realidad es una
diferencia o cambio de velocidad donde
la velocidad es igual a la aceleración
por el tiempo de hecho esta fórmula
también se pudo haber escrito a sí
velocidad final
menos velocidad inicial es igual a la
aceleración por el tiempo donde
velocidad final menos velocidad inicial
es la diferencia en la velocidad
de hecho esta es la manera en la que se
debe ser y aquí se dan cuenta de que
pues bueno se hacen las cosas como se me
ocurren en el momento pero se hace de
esta manera por una razón ya que
queremos que ustedes adquieran la misma
intención que nosotros queremos tener en
lugar de estar haciendo las cosas de una
manera muy formal como en un libro ya
que a veces el libro no necesariamente
nos ayuda a hacer conexiones de manera
natural así que esto sale directamente
de nuestro cerebro al vídeo y si tenemos
suerte llegará a su cerebro
estas son diferentes maneras de expresar
lo mismo y de hecho deberíamos escribir
esto como el cambio en la velocidad
vamos a escribirlo un poco más abajo el
cambio en la velocidad del tav
es igual a la aceleración por el tiempo
donde este triangulito llamado delta
significa cambio o diferencia
entonces bueno tenemos que la velocidad
final menos la velocidad inicial es
igual a la aceleración por el tiempo y
tenemos que la velocidad promedio
es igual a la velocidad final más la
velocidad inicial entre 2 entonces
sustituimos estas operaciones y tenemos
que la velocidad promedio es igual a la
velocidad inicial más la aceleración por
el tiempo entre 2 y entonces que se me
acaba el tiempo en el vídeo anterior les
dije que vamos a tomar esta fórmula de
la velocidad promedio y en verdad le
sugiero que ustedes jueguen con estas
fórmulas y las deriven por ustedes
mismos ya que les va a ayudar mucho
cuando se les olviden las fórmulas en un
examen pues de cualquier manera ustedes
sabrán cómo deducirles entonces tenemos
que la fórmula para la velocidad
promedio se sustituye en la ecuación de
distancia y tenemos que la distancia es
igual a la velocidad inicial más la
aceleración por el tiempo entre 2 y todo
esto multiplicado por el tiempo
vamos a desarrollar esta fórmula y
tenemos que este tiempo lo vamos a
multiplicar por estos dos términos y nos
queda velocidad inicial por el tiempo
más la aceleración por el tiempo al
cuadrado entre 2
y quizás sus maestros de física les
digan o les enseñan que la distancia es
igual a la aceleración por el tiempo al
cuadrado entre 2 y le dicen que lo
memoricen esto es porque muchos de los
problemas de movimiento de proyectiles
la velocidad inicial es cero por lo que
este término se cancela y solo nos queda
este término
y si ustedes resuelven el último
problema que vimos en el vídeo pasado
usando esta fórmula obtendrán el mismo
resultado bueno si recordamos el
problema era que tenemos la aceleración
de la gravedad igual a 10
metros sobre segundo al cuadrado
nuestro tiempo era igual a 2 segundos
y la velocidad inicial como estábamos
tirando una moneda desde un edificio
alto la velocidad inicial era igual a
cero
entonces
vamos a poner nuestros valores en la
fórmula tenemos que la distancia es
igual a la velocidad inicial que bueno
es 0 se cancela este término más la
aceleración que en este caso la
aceleración es 10 metros sobre segundo
al cuadrado
por el tiempo al cuadrado el tiempo es 2
segundos si lo hacemos el cuadrado vamos
a tener 4 y también las unidades las que
llevamos al cuadrado cuatro segundos al
cuadrado
todo esto dividido entre 2
entonces bueno multiplicamos el valor 10
por 4
nos queda un 40
no nos olvidamos de multiplicar las
unidades metros entre segundo al
cuadrado por segundo al cuadrado se
cancelan estos y nos quedamos con las
unidades de metro y esto lo dividimos
entre 2
tenemos 40 entre 2 nos queda 20 metros
que era exactamente el valor que
obtuvimos en la ocasión anterior y vamos
a dejarlo hasta este punto y en la
siguiente presentación exploraremos con
más detalle estos mecanismos